all right i'm calling an audible pete
sorry i just texted everyone apparently
philip rivers is retiring oh that word
just coming out um phillip rivers
retires from the nfl after 17 seasons it
is official the san diego union tribune
with that report slash announcement so
he's given his original hometown paper
at least nfl hometown paper gave the
exclusive to kevin ac who covered that
team and a perfect lead the time has
come dad gummit that's
not a quote from rivers that's the kevin
ac line to start it off so uh hey
there's been talk
that fox wants him or some other network
wants him
i think he should go straight to the
broadcast booth i think he will be
awesome i think he will be everything
that we've expected that peyton manning
would be
and uh i can't wait to watch a game
called by philip rivers i think that's
inevitable and i think maybe he's doing
it now because someone is dangling that
cash in front of him and he's realizing
i can make this much to play football i
can make this much to talk about
football yeah i'm going to start talking
about football instead uh he i i agree
he's going to be great at that job if he
does decide to do that sorry to see him
go i mean
not a hall of fame quarterback but an
nfl legend like that that's where i
always put philip rivers in and
toughness you know competitive talking
crap i loved all those things about
phillip rivers i really do and you know
consecutive game starts there's another
guy like brett favre where to me his
consecutive game start
uh streak is more impressive because he
played a pretty physical brand as far as
i'm gonna stand in the pocket i don't
give a damn if you're gonna hit me and
he was still doing that even this year
but
i think it was the right time
you know i think another year yeah he
might have been able to win some
football games but i think it would have
been glaring that he was the weak spot
on the football team next year so good
for him amazing career hope he kicks
butt announcing football games
fifth and there's no guarantee he's
going to do it because what he told
kevin acey is he's doing it because he
wants to coach high school football st
michael catholic high school in fairhope
alabama he took that job last year
effective whenever he retires he said
what has helped me come to this decision
is the growing desire to coach high
school football that's what i've always
wanted to do it's been growing i can't i
could wait so so if hey
fox cbs any other network out there
including the one we're on if you're
looking at philip rivers you you better
understand that you're only getting him
with uh this caveat that he's coached in
st michael high school yeah
there's lots of friday night football
games uh that's for sure because that's
gonna make life life hard but uh if he's
offered 18 million dollars a year he
might be able to manipulate that
schedule to where it is all friday night
schedules friday night games
and one last thing because we have to
take a break and we'll surely be talking
plenty about philip rivers in the days
to come he specifically chose apparently
january 20 to announce his retirement
because he's a devout catholic and today
is the saint sebastian feast day and
saint sebastian is often referred to as
the patron saint of athletes so um
good for philip rivers to go out on his
terms he could have made it one more
year with the colts or someone else he's
still got the skill set he's walking
away with gas in the tank but he's got
another tank full of gas that he wants
to start burning up and that is being a
high school football coach and kudos to
him for making that decision
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports